a sudden decision to drop criminal
charges against actor justice Millette
in Chicago is bringing angry reaction
puzzling head-scratching and raising
major legal questions the city's Mayor
Rahm Emanuel calls it a whitewash of
justice
Chicago's police union wants the Justice
Department to investigate Smollett was
charged with 16 felony counts earlier
this month after allegedly lying to
police that he was targeted in a hate
crime attack the cast member of Empire
denies the allegations prosecutors
indicate they have more important cases
to pursue a big head scratcher Adriana
Diaz is in Chicago with the decision
that came with no warning and very
little explanation
Adriana good morning good morning the
charges were dropped after Smollett
performed just two days of community
service this week and agreed to forfeit
ten thousand dollars bond
even though we're told the city's spent
more than a hundred and fifty thousand
on his case now in this building we
interviewed the man who decided to drop
those charges he thinks Smollett is
guilty but small LED is using this news
to prove his innocence now city leaders
are furious because they say the
evidence against the actor is
overwhelming mr. Smollett is still
saying that he is innocent still running
down the Chicago Police Department
oh dear him Chicago Mayor Rahm Emanuel
could barely contain his outrage at the
decision to drop charges against actor
Jesse Smollett this sends an unambiguous
message that there is no accountability
and that is wrong Chicago Police
Superintendent Eddie Johnson says his
department was blindsided this mr.
Smollett who committed this whole period
if he wanted to clear his name the way
to do that was in a court of law
so that everyone could see the evidence
small let's attorneys that his record
was wiped clean of the 16 felony counts
of disorderly conduct
each punishable by up to three years in
prison the actor remained unapologetic
while maintaining his innocence
I've been truthful and consistent on
every single level since day one
prosecutors accused Smollett of lying to
police about being attacked in the
middle of the night by two white men who
shouted racist and homophobic slurs but
it was these two brothers who admitted
under oath that Smollett paid them to do
it
I would not be my mother's son if I was
capable of one drop of what I was been
accused of investigators have said the
36 year-old who's openly gay made the
report to get publicity in hopes of
gaining a larger salary on the TV drama
Empire state prosecutor Joma GATS
is the person who made the decision to
drop the charges he believes Smollett
made up the allegations but says the
nonviolent case qualifies for community
service and a financial penalty which he
says is common practice so you believe
he's guilty yes
so why drop the charges our priority is
Violent Crimes and the drivers of
violence Jesse Smollett is neither one
of those and it's community service and
$10,000 enough to wipe this clean I feel
that it is CBS News legal analyst Ricky
Kleeman calls the latest twist beyond
unusual you have a 16 count indictment
and then within a very short period of
time the case gets dismissed by the
prosecution and it gets sealed unusual
is almost not strong enough of a word
we've learned that city lawyers are
trying to determine if they can release
evidence from this investigation even
though the judge sealed the case
meanwhile the FBI is still investigating
a threatening letter that Smollett
allegedly sent to himself so his legal
troubles are far from over Alex the
story is far from over we all have a lot
of questions Adriana thank you for that
reporting